hey what's up guys my name is a cha know
and welcome to a video that will show
you how you can contribute to Sparky so
Sparky of course is a game engine that
I've been working on for just over a
year now it's a 2d and 3d game engine
that is pretty early in development
still there's a lot going on and it's a
huge project and if this is the first
time you're hearing of it I recommend
that you take a look at the dev logs
because they'll kind of fill you in on
what's going on and all the new stuff
that I'm working on and kind of will
need help with and all that stuff but
this video is just going to cover how
you can actually go from looking at the
repository on github here which is just
github com for / the jono for Sparky the
link to that will be in the description
below of how you can go from like
looking at this repository to actually
submitting pull requests and how you
should be writing code for Sparky and
kind of how the whole process is going
to work so the first thing you're going
to want to do is make a github account
if you don't already have one I'm sure a
lot of you already do have github
accounts but if you navigate to the
repository I mean step one obviously
you're gonna have to like hit the start
button i mean that's like that's the
first thing you should do but that aside
once you to do that you're going to want
to basically just fork the engine right
so the way this is going to work i'll
kind of like in this video I'll
basically cover everything you need to
go from just this tube like essentially
submitting a pull request and then I'll
talk about like more or less what you
should be doing in Sparky so we'll cover
the the hell not not the what to begin
with so if I just hit the fault button
i'm logged in by the way is just another
user nothing it hub user kinda i have is
called the turnip raj so that's what i'm
kind of going to be using here if I hit
the fork button essentially I mean it's
as simple as that right I'm now looking
at its parking on my kind of repository
right so then what I want to do is I
essentially want to clone this on my
computer make changes to this commit to
this and then eventually you know open a
port
qwest right which is pretty easy to do
so this is what I'll do I'll kind of
cover that with you guys so you want to
take the URL that you've got right which
is going to look something like this may
i'll probably have a dot get on the end
but you can see that this is the this is
this is my version of Sparky right like
the version that is on the channel
approach not the cherno i'm going to
copy that i'm going to find a nice
directory on my hard drive here
somewhere maybe over here all right over
here for example I've got a nice
directory I'm going to well cover the
command line for you guys but if you
have something like taught us get of
course you can just right-click hit git
clone and then clone it but if you just
type in get clone and then you paste in
the name of the the URL here then it
will start kind of cloning that so this
will take a while probably a mail I'll
let you guys know how long it'll take
but it should take like might take like
10 minutes or so so i'll see you guys in
a minute alright so ten minutes or so
later when this is all done you will
have Sparky in your thing right um I
should say on on your computer so once
you have that just open that with visual
studio 2015 you can get community for
free from the internet if you go to
visual studio visual studio com there'll
be a link in the description you can
download visual studio 2015 community
it's completely free and it will open
this up fine for you and you'll be able
to do everything so anyway once you've
got that and you've opened this up let's
talk about how we can modify this and
submit a change so first of all when you
open the repository you'll probably like
I mean you should you should see this
once you open the visual studio solution
or march it might take a little bit of
time here to pass everything that um
what's going on but the way that it's
set up there are a few things you want
to change so first of all first of all
in the configuration here it will be set
to mixed platforms change that to win 32
mixed platforms will only apply to the
c-sharp project but just so you know
when 32 is the project is the only
platform that we are
please support right now so you
definitely want to make sure that you're
set on that because we're problem with
other platforms is there then just not
configured so x64 for example I don't
believe that like I mean sandbox is even
have an x64 config but if it did whoops
let's let's cancel out but if it did
it's a it wouldn't like having have
anything set up anyway so next step is
these two projects the best thing to do
with them because they don't work is to
just right-click them and help unload
you don't have to do this but if you try
and build them you'll get error messages
in your error list and stuff like that
if you try and build them because the
day weren't built right so if you don't
want to see though there are messages
and you don't want to see them pop up in
your file searching and all that stuff
then the best thing to do is just to
right click on them and hit unload great
now that we've got that we can take a
look at this kind of stuff so inside
sandbox let's just open up I don't know
the file I mean we don't really have to
open file but there we go cool got file
let's debug win32 right with the sandbox
set as the starter project let's just
hit the local windows debugger button
here and wait for that to compile
everything so it'll take about I mean
the first time you compile the stuff it
will probably take around two to three
minutes so the big things are going to
be like free image takes a lot of time
so the two big projects here that will
take forever to compile a free image and
a sparky core everything else should be
fairly quick so any time you make a
change to like a free image had a file
or something you're going to have to sit
through a long build but basically once
these dependencies are built you can
literally just like unload them if you
want or you can just kind of ignore them
because you won't be really doing
anything with them probably right it's
not a very typical case to have to
modify them because I've kind of set
them up to be good alright so we're
building Sparky Cornell
so I'll take like a minute or so 30
seconds maybe okay and well that's well
that's going on I'll kind of expand a
little bit on what's going on here so
maybe I'll just wait for it it's almost
done i think yep almost done come on yay
okay and then finally sandbox which
won't take too long ago and sandbox is
on okay great so now it's opening and it
should run fine all right cool so here
we have sandbox and you can see
everything's running well and this is
for set to direct x here so everything's
everything's pretty good so this is how
you get so you get Sparkie running this
is how this is how you build it yourself
it's really easy right I've made it so
that you don't actually have to do
anything all the dependencies are
contained within the Sparky repository
right as you can see so there's
absolutely no need to go ahead and hook
up paths or download extra stuff now you
just get the Sparky repository and then
you run it now the really important
thing that I need to point out is that
you may actually get errors if you don't
have the microsoft windows sdk installed
okay the reason that's required is
because the direct tax context creates
the context using the debug like the
crew you're using the flag d3d11 create
deep prayer device debug okay so it
creates the debug layer if you want to
use the debug layer you need to have the
windows sdk installed okay otherwise it
won't work and it will complain about
couldn't create device and you'll get a
crash so basically this flag will get
removed obviously when like you feel
like production coding for distribution
builds but for debug builds and possibly
even release builds that would be on and
I just haven't set it up right now so
that you can just sort of it gets
switched off based on the
configurational that there's a macro
learning that will switch it off so it's
always on right now which is fine
because if you're developing you know
we're developing this engine so you
should have in windows sdk
installed anyway so that's just let me
to watch out for I know a few people
were getting this crash because of this
so make sure you have the windows sdk
installed that's the only requirement
and as only if you want to use direct
acts which you will you'll have to if
you wish to open jailed oh and you don't
have the windows sdk installed it should
just run fine so we'll just quickly
check that out alright cool so there we
go so that that's running fine I know
nothing record nothing is really going
wrong cool no crashes or anything here's
what I meant okay brilliant so let's
just say we changed something right
let's just take a look at something that
we can change I don't know I don't think
there's anything that's just yelling out
at me that could get changed I'm
literally looking for really like really
basic stuff just so i can change
something but I don't know it's pretty
perfect isn't it um so let's go into a
good a good thing to change would be
something like this right so these types
right now using like char short and long
for example they should really be using
something like int 8 on the score t
right kind of the C++ defines so if we
just quickly change them to use those
for example I think that would be a
decent change that we can commit and
I'll i might actually merge it because
i've been meaning to do this for a while
so you inc Ewing this is cool we're
actually going to contribute to Sparky
live on this video amazing all right
oops so now you've got those sorted out
let's talk about how we can commit that
so you're going to want to do a few
things first of all I just by the way I
just change that didn't even compile it
so make sure you make sure you build the
project first that's step one make sure
it compiles okay and not only mate not
only that but
you'll have to also make sure that it
works in both debug and release okay we
don't have a QA department so you can't
just be like all my code compiles so
it's qas problem no that's not how this
works okay you need to make sure that
your code works I mean this goes without
saying but I'm just I'm saying it anyway
you didn't make sure that it works in
both release and debug right now again
we support one platform so it's easy you
just need to just just hit f5 make sure
works if you're doing any kind of
graphics changes or anything like that
make sure that it works in both directx
and opengl mode but you can see that
this seems to be functional which is
good so we can commit it so what you can
do now is you can just all open this
file for example you can see that that
file has been modified and I can
literally commit it if you're not using
tortoise get then you can just obviously
do something like get add you know types
whatever and add in you can even diff it
as well you can see what we change I
mean we changed a few things but really
types the only one we want to commit
make sure you don't commit any changes
to sandbox if you're they're not like
sandbox related for example you know I
mean like on my local branch on my local
copy here I switch that to OpenGL but
it's committed as direct I so obviously
that's not relevant to this change also
don't commit any binaries at the
beginning I did commit binaries and you
can see that we do actually have that
but I've kind of stopped doing that in
fact I don't think we do commit binaries
anymore at all yeah we don't we ideally
would get continuous integration set up
the reason we don't commit binaries is
because they've become over 100 mega
like Sparky Sparky core dot lib becomes
over 100 Meg one is in debug in fact I
think I can just check that right now SB
cordiello and maybe not the core anyway
something I remember was like or maybe
really special I thought something was
over 100 Meg it sound like okay fine
normal binaries so anyway um ideally we
would be doing that but we're not anyway
the important thing is to not commit any
files that don't need committing like
for example the precompiled headers we
don't want to commit any of that stuff
just make sure that you do you know what
you
doing and only committing the stuff that
you need ah the we need okay cool so
anyway let's go on to let's go find that
file that we changed types right I'll
use tortoise get from now on we can just
dip it to verify that the changes we've
made our actually what we want you can
see they are that looks pretty good to
me so let's do a git commit to master
okay changed integer type deaths to C++
standard sure just type in a message
that makes sense and it describes
everything you've done if you changed a
whole bunch of stuff split it up into
different commit messages but that looks
pretty good typedefs I'll do that okay
cool and then just hit commit then hit
push so we'll push on to the channel
proj like to remember my password yep
good so now right if i refresh this
you'll see that I've actually done
something and it's recognizing me as the
channel because I'm set up that way but
anyway pretended that the cherno proj
has done that so that's good so now all
we have to do is actually open a pull
request okay so to open a pull request
navigate to the actual repository so not
your one but the actual the cherno /
Sparky repository hit the new pull
request button okay now what we'll do is
you'll see the compare across folks
thing because this is just between local
branches I don't know why it's set to
that by default that seems to be weird
but anyway compared against forks and
then this is the base so this is the
this will always be the show no such
Sparky if you're merging into that which
is what we're doing we're opening a pull
request to merge into that and then the
head fork becomes your your actual fork
of Sparky so the trainer approach / The
Barking in our case okay this of course
brings up our commit mass
edge and it brings up all of our files
and everything is pretty good right so
this looks good to me it's got the death
of course that's the thing that we did
so I'll leave a comment I'm a dad I'm
not gonna leave a comment in this case
but you just hit the create pull request
button once you leave a comment with
what you've actually done make sure hear
that first of all you don't have an
overload of commits of commit messages
and commits right I usually squash all
of them into one commit anyway unless
you've done like because a lot of a lot
of people will obviously and it's fine
like if you're just like I you know if
you commit again in cuz you're like I
you know forgot to add a file or forgot
to do this that I obviously we'll just
squish them into one commit because I
don't want to clutter up the repository
but just kind of make sure that
everything here is as clear as possible
ok so once we create that pull request
it becomes an official / an official
pull request on Sparky's thing right and
then all I have to do now is essentially
just merge that in right so on my side I
mean this isn't really going to be
relevant to you guys that much but on my
side if I actually open up a things
logged in with me forgot to pull
requests I'll probably I'm a comment
here and I may be like I'll obviously
look at the commits and stuff that
you've changed and I'm quickly just
verify that that's correct okay good and
then you know I might ask you to do
something and if I'm happy with it I
will usually just squash this and you
know either merge or usually squash it's
the way I likes like squashing things so
there you go changing to tie vest blah
confirm squash merge done and now we
have gone to actually commit into that
and that's completely done now okay so
that's how that works it's pretty it's
pretty simple and there's not much to it
and you can see that yeah we've
successfully changed something in the
engine which is pretty cool so there you
go i'm going to i have been accepting
pull requests if you look
to commence by the way a bunch of them
aren't even by me like there's you know
this this these two right I'm I'm
totally letting you guys do this stuff
don't think that I'm going to be really
judgmental or protective of this by no
means I am I like that right I really
want you guys to contribute early want
you guys to help so if you don't know
what to do and you just want to help and
you're not exactly sure like the best
way really to go about this is probably
to start using Sparky and you'll see a
bunch of things as it is very wrong with
it that you can obviously improve okay
and that's kind of one thing you could
do and the other thing is if you hop on
over the issues like I am going to start
opening issues here they're a bunch of
issues already on Sparky's Trello right
so if you go to bit early for life's
lucky Trello that's like the Trello
board and that will have like a bunch of
like issues presented issues but a lot
of them are really under debt but like
this one for example and I'm kind of
trying to mirror them on this actual
issue thing so you see for example that
this is an issue that I opened a couple
days ago where we can't generate me map
so you might be like oh I know how to do
that or I could fix that so fix it mum
fix it assign yourself to it if you like
I don't know if you can do that actually
but maybe you can maybe I have to assign
it but just leave a comment being like
I'm working on it or I'm on the case or
something like that and and then you can
eventually open up open a pull request
you can also obviously share your
opinions on certain pulled requests and
stuff over here and you know just go
through stuff I was going to say that I
will typically leave comments as well
for example if there's a commit that if
there's a pull request that generally is
good like this one however there are
some things that need to be changed I'll
you know leave a list for you and then
you can change it or you can tell me why
you don't want to change it and we can
talk about it and all that stuff right
so don't be afraid just just jump in
there rice and code and and hopefully
all of our
fool contributor spark and make it a
much better engine so that's pretty much
going to wrap up this video I'm going to
make another video hopefully this week
on actual specifics of how you should
write code for Sparky because a lot of
people are really not sure about that
and that's totally fine I mean the rule
to get started for you right now like
just so that you can get started the
quick rule is just look at other code
right look a code that is around you
yeah if you're changing something like
if you look at direct extra texture 2d
and you're fixing that mipmap that the
mapping generation bug right and you see
that for example you know I mean
variables that I'm declaring if we go
over here and you need to make a new I
don't know why you would be let's just
say you do need to make a new bullying
that's like to generate move apps or
whatever don't do something like
generate maps right you can see that
clearly the convention for this is to
have an M underscore and then a capital
here to like four fields right so just
kind of be aware of the code that's
around you obviously if you guys have
had experienced collaborating with
people are working working like you know
having like if you're a software
engineers has a career then this won't
be a problem for you but if you're kind
of just starting out just look at the
look at the code that is around you if
you don't know how to do something for
example you might be like okay what's
the sounded way too like a log something
in Sparky I mean just take a look at the
code that's in the engine already
because most likely what you're trying
to do has already sort of been done in
some compares in some capacity right as
in like something especially as simple
as logging has obviously been done and
it might not be that easy to check but
actually like another thing you could
definitely do is just run it for example
you see that like I do stuff like you
know log and you might be like oh I
wonder how he logs in yellow like I want
to do that because that'd be useful or
whatever how does he do that so it looks
like he prints large allocation let's
just search for the text large
allocation oh look here it is oh he's SP
warned to do that right simple just kind
of do stuff like that
and we'll definitely cover that in more
depth when we get into you know that
specific video but just for now just
kind of look at look at look at
neighboring code and try and blend in
that's that's the pro strategy okay cool
thanks for watching guys if you enjoy
this video please hit like button and
I'll see you guys next time get back